You might wonder if your dog could qualify to be a guide dog.
You can get an idea by observing them.
Research has shown that dogs are left or right-pawed.
Are you a left-footer, Max?
Hey, are you a left-footer?
No?
You can test this by watching closely to see which paw they step off with.
I think that was a right foot starter.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's left-footed, isn't she?
You're left-handed.
Okay, let's go.
I think we've proven there in that unbiased test that it was his right foot that came forward.
Preliminary research has shown that right-pawed dogs...
...are statistically more likely to pass the guide dog test.
You'd get run over by the bus, you would, wouldn't you?
There's another clue to the chances of them passing:...
...in the swirls of hair on your dog.
And it all depends which way they turn.
Clockwise.
Anticlockwise.
If your dog is right-pawed and the swirl goes anticlockwise,...
...then your dog is more likely to be calm, confident and self-assured.
Exactly the traits that a guide dog needs.